chrissy teigen recently made headlines
when president biden
followed her on twitter because she like
asked him when he got into office
because basically
you know she was uh i think blocked for
four years
i don't think she was a fan of the past
person who had that nor was he of her so
that was a non-starter
and so she made a profession would you
please follow me i'd love to be a part
of this administration
he i guess obliged they made friends
she recently said you know what i'm not
being myself because
i'm so kind of afraid of your opinion
of me and i'm i gotta be me so will you
please unfollow me
and the best thing is he did he totally
unfollowed her and i think anybody
who is friends with their grandma on
facebook understands what chrissy teigen
felt in this moment you know you think
you want the president to follow you and
then
suddenly you can't tweet you know if you
follow her you know the kind of stuff
she tweets she couldn't do that with him
watching so i thought that's
so hilarious that he obliged i think
what i find so charming about this story
is that we
all have these kind of dual
personalities
and the other day i had this puritan i
was all in white you know birthday
show and it was just it was such a this
is your life moment i'm crying the whole
time i don't even know how they edited a
show out of it so i was like oh
the whole show and then i go on howard
stern and i'm very straightforward and i
get to curse and you know it's this
whole other side of me
but they're both me yeah and so i really
get what she's saying
and there are times where we would like
to project a certain thing
and there's times where we'd like to
project something else still the same
person
but we all do a path life so i get it do
you
ever um second guess putting something
out there because of who you know is
watching you
i think with all things in life social
media included
is if your gut instinct is questioning
it don't
do it that gut instinct that jiminy
cricket that conscience
is there for a reason so if you're
questioning it
stop questioning it and just say no yeah
i wouldn't mind if joe biden followed me
um i post a lot about my dogs so
if you like that sort of thing oh my
gosh at hello ross i
yeah of course